10 assez lumineuse agréable et 6e en
attente
après trois ans de travaux professeurs
et élèves sont contents de découvrir cet
établissement totalement restructuré 10
millions d'euros financés par le
département collège comme neuf et
nouveau chef d'établissement pour cette
rentrée 2010 9 465 élèves actuellement
j'arrive effectivement pour ma première
rentrée dans ce collège et je découvre
des locaux quasi neufs et une très bonne
ambiance de travail avec une équipe
motivée
au total c'est une enveloppe de 160
millions d'euros qui a été consacrée au
fonctionnement et à l'investissement des
établissements du département en 2019 la
collectivité présenté lundi 9 septembre
les principales nouveautés de cette
rentrée nous avons décidé de mettre à
disposition des collèges des charges et
de prévention il y en aura 22 qui
interviendront dans 30 collèges dès le
mois de janvier 2020 c'est un dispositif
qui permet d'aider les jeunes
dans leur recherche de stage mais aussi
de gérer les conflits
la vidéoprotection sera implanté dans
tous les établissements après un test
réussi dans trois d'entre eux un accent
fort est également mise sur le numérique
l'espace numérique de travail propose
désormais une aide aux devoirs
généralisée l'outil numérique sert
également dans l'inclusion des élèves
malades ou en situation de handicap
enfin les initiatives communes entre
yvelines et hauts-de-seine se
poursuivent avec plusieurs projets
pédagogiques en commun
[Applaudissements]